our disgusting tale of anomalous
nastiness begins in the humble town of
beckley west virginia back in the 1990s
it was 10 a.m on a hot day in early
august as oscar doug was winding his way
through the wooded roads and back
streets of town he isn't the villain of
our story he's just a man doing his very
unglamorous job cleaning up roadkill for
the local government plenty of woodland
critters meet their ends against the
wheels and bumpers of careless drivers
and it was thanks to the tireless work
of people like oscar doug that the fine
roads of rural america aren't piled high
with carcasses of course oscar was used
to seeing some unpleasant things on the
job but nothing
like this
when he began pulling over to the side
of the lonely street to pick up a dead
deer he was shocked to see a sudden
flash of stark white illuminated by his
headlights it was a naked human woman
crouched over the deer carcass she was
sucking at the exposed red flesh on the
deer's flank as though feeding off of it
flies circled around her in the hot
summer air the smell emerging from the
deer carcass was unspeakable but the
woman didn't even seem to care she just
fed away with a crazed look in her eye
and even more disturbing was the fact
that he recognized her it was mrs faber
a local eccentric who lived with her
husband on a farm just outside of town
or at least she had you see oscar doug
had never met mrs faber in person before
he only recognized her from the missing
person flyers posted around town he
pulled out his cell phone to call the
authorities when suddenly mrs faber was
startled by something and fled into the
woods
this would be the first of many
encounters reported by townsfolk
concerning mrs faber or more
specifically the anomalous species that
was once mrs faber and is now designated
scp-726
mrs faber practically became a local
cryptid similar to that of sasquatch or
the loch ness monster with sightings of
her in the woods and around town
frequently being reported by the locals
of course mr faber was beside himself
about the whole situation what was
happening to his beloved wife people
assumed a psychotic break or some kind
of sudden onset of acute dementia she
had to be apprehended and brought in for
her own good before she caused harm to
herself or others and on august 16th she
was finally found and captured mrs faber
was found in the dumpster of a local
diner with a large dog after being
subdued she was sent to a nearby
hospital her condition had seemingly
advanced to the point where she was no
longer even capable of speech however if
it had ended there the scp foundation
wouldn't have been called in it would
have just been a sad local story of a
woman who became very unwell but that
was only the beginning to the true
strangeness behind
scp-726 random livestock like cows and
pigs were found across the town behaving
incredibly bizarre exhibiting actions
and traits uncommon of their respective
species and the most shocking of all was
that the sightings of mrs faber around
town still didn't stop despite her being
actively held by a local hospital
naturally that's when the scp foundation
decided to take control of the situation
they dispatched field agents to properly
investigate and figure out what was
going on in beckley west virginia that's
when they discovered a peculiar
commonality
maggots you see the behavior exhibited
by the strange animals and by mrs faber
was not consistent with their own
species but they were incredibly
consistent with the behaviors of the
common botfly a particularly unpleasant
form of fly that sometimes lays its eggs
in the bodies of still living animals
the anomalously affected entities
exhibited insectoid movements an
affinity for rotting meat and even
strange shifting of the back muscles
suggesting the gesture of flapping wings
that weren't there but what was going on
here was this mind control or something
more insidious as it turned out
the key to unlocking this mystery was in
the dumpster that mrs faber was found in
an entire pig was found inside the
dumpster exhibiting the same strange
behaviors as the other anomalous animals
but not long before it was transformed
into a pig it was simply a half-eaten
hot dog thrown to waste in the garbage
this miraculous transformation came
courtesy of scp-726
now also known as the reconstructive
maggots much like regular maggots these
creatures are attracted to decaying
flesh and will multiply and consume dead
bodies or rotten food rapidly however
the truly strange thing is what happens
afterward the maggots will expel
purified waste matter which then
reconstitutes back into a kind of living
exact clone of the entity it once was
well exact in a physical sense in a
psychological sense these clones are
exactly like a mature botfly the maggots
that reconstitute these bodies die off
almost immediately but whenever two of
these clones mate with reproductive
behavior often being inspired by the
presence of carcasses or spoiled meat
they produce more eggs which in turn
release
scp-726 maggots and begin the cycle all
over again
and fascinatingly these maggots can
reconstitute an entire clone from even a
portion of the original creature which
begs the question why were there
seemingly multiple mrs fabers cited in
and around the town of beckley west
virginia upon further investigation into
mrs faber and her husband a terrible
secret came to light mr faber had
murdered his wife in a fit of rage and
cut up her body before burying the
pieces around the grounds of his home
unbeknownst to him an infestation of
scp-726 maggots across the property ate
each piece and reconstituted them into
individual fly-brained clones of the
original mr faber was later arrested for
the murder and multiple people in the
town of beckley were given amnestic
treatment to forget the strange and
frightening things they'd seen but for
the foundation the strange and
frightening things were only just
beginning an unnamed doctor with the scp
foundation decided to conduct a series
of utterly repulsive experiments on
scp-726
opening the log with the fateful words
i've decided to begin by testing the
limits of repeated replication a single
scp-726 egg will be introduced per
sample due to their rapid multiplication
maggot volume does not affect their
speed of operation only the size of the
organism to be reconstructed the first
subject was a recently deceased
norwegian rat cut in half lengthwise
when the scp-726 eggs were introduced
the two halves were rapidly constituted
into a pair of living rats with mirrored
fur patterns both of these rats were
then ground into a fine paste and mixed
wondering if scp-726 would create a
hybrid they did not instead separating
the mix into two piles and once again
creating two rats nearly identical to
the ones before except for one of them
now having a red right eye the rat
without the red right eye was processed
into a fine paste get used to hearing
that phrase before the introduction of
more scp-726
samples it reproduced a close
approximation of the rat it once was
aside from a slight limp and blindness
in both eyes the heart was then taken
from this rat and upon the introduction
of scp-726 into the heart it was
reconstituted without eyes or any
pigmentation
a note also mentions that the creature
squeaked incessantly the heart from this
rat was then taken and cut in half
before
scp-726 was introduced the result was a
pair of even more severely messed up
eyeless rats one could only walk in
tight circles and the other immediately
attacked the first rat the doctor noted
that both physiology and insect behavior
seemed to degrade with repeated
reconstitutions of the same genetic
material
next a scrap of flesh was taken from the
hairless rat the creature that
reconstituted from this was hairless
eyeless and limbless and didn't
successfully survive for long a liver
was found inside its brain case but
because this particular researcher
hadn't spit in the face of god enough
for one day the tests continued the
liver from the brainless rat was given a
dose of scp-726
and the result was an eyeless legless
limbless creature with a long worm-like
mid-section which quickly began to
devour its own posterior before dying of
blood loss this dead rat was then put
through three more iterations of testing
it first became a large formless mass of
tissue and then a long slug-like
creature that takes in nutrients through
its skin after this no more changes were
recorded as it had presumably reached
its peak performance the scientists
decided to keep this creature for
long-term observation naming it brundle
after the scientist in david
kronenberg's remake of the fly
at this point the doctor began to
conduct tests that mercifully did not
involve any more rats instead the
foundation moved on to humans dried
flesh from a body that's over 2000 years
old was given to scp-726
leading to a full reconstitution of a
middle-aged man with the mind of a fly
opening doors to potential practical
forensic applications of scp-726
humans seem to experience a similar
degree of form degradation after
multiple reconstitutions from the same
genetic material but due to humans being
larger and more complex organisms the
changes are often less pronounced like
changes in eye color or fingerprints
while the forensic use of scp-726 is an
open door clones produced by scp-726 are
worthless for both medical and food
purposes during one experiment
scp-726 was used to replace a missing
chunk of a wounded d-class's leg this
appeared to be successful at first until
the d-class later experienced a rapid
mental devolution into a fly-like state
just like the other victims of scp-726
the d-class was terminated and the test
was recorded as a failure it's believed
that a similar thing would happen if
organ transplants were taken out of
scp-726 clones and given to
non-anomalous donors
scp-726 was used to clone several
livestock animals such as cows and pigs
food items like steaks were rendered
from these animals cooked and given to
d-classes much like the transplants this
led to a similar state of devolution for
those who ate the infected meat even
when the meat was thoroughly disinfected
and processed the anomalous effects
remained so no
scp-726 won't be ending world hunger
anytime soon though if it gave us all
the minds of flies through tainted meat
it may at least end all global warfare
seeing as flies don't have the mental
capacity to create or wield weapons at
this point it seemed that the researcher
was just curious and felt like trying
some other random experiments just for
the heck of it like getting scp-726 to
reconstitute a non-anomalous botfly
leading to the clone simply being an
unusually large botfly which died
shortly thereafter or testing a burger
patty from a local independent
drive-thru restaurant that reconstituted
into two different cows and one large
rat yummy but the most horrifying result
of all came when they tested
scp-726 on what was supposedly a vegan
burger made entirely out of artificial
meat and plant matter the resulting
creatures were so unimaginably
horrifying they literally cannot be
described even hardened scp foundation
researchers were driven to scream and
vomit at the mere sight of them one of
these creatures was killed and ground
into fine pace before scp-726 was
introduced again somehow this resulted
in something even worse a truly
horrifying unkillable entity on par with
scp-682
even when they liquefied the beast it
kept attacking they could only stop it
by freezing it and keeping it on ice
testing into
scp-726 was suspended shortly thereafter
huh maggots spot flies and rat paste how
lovely if you were eating during any of
this well you only have yourself to
blame now go check out
scp-2852 sadistic madman party crasher
cousin johnny and
scp-5049 the skin salesman demon dance
discount homunculus depot for more
terrifying tales of anomalous body
horror